the number one Turner for women is
neediness what's your thoughts on that
neediness is very different from having
needs neediness is saying I can't find
Solutions I'm going to lay here crying
until someone else solves my problem for
me it is not like most men say being a
completely immovable stone that never
has a weakness because women don't want
that either they want to see that you
have vulnerabilities and challenges that
they can help you with but they also
want to see you rising to the occasion
and solving those problems because they
want and respect a man who views
Solutions and approaches them and
applies them they assume she doesn't
want to hear from them again because she
wasn't explicitly throwing herself at
him so many guys who navigate from Red
Pill into regular dating and say she
didn't try to sleep with me what's wrong
with me and they build validation based
on if she's trying to have sex with him
and women do this too if you don't
understand what real interest from a
securely attached person looks like you
think they are uninterested or bored or
boring